what is going on everybody welcome to
another sentiment analysis tutorial i
get a lot emails from people who want to
do twitter analysis but we're having a
hard time figuring out how to measure
someone's impact on twitter right
because not everybody has the same
impact as everyone else and it's
certainly not measured solely by the
number of followers nor the follower to
following ratio so what i want to do in
this video is just kind of go over a
starting point to measuring someone's
impact on twitter because everyone's
opinion on twitter is not this is not
worth the same right and so anyway yeah
let's go ahead and get into it so we see
here we're wheeling this guy blues ER
twelve and right off the top we see he's
got a very unbalanced follower it
following the followers ratio right and
the lower the following two followers
ratio the better right or the higher
followers the following ratio the better
so but that's not the only thing we
would want to look at right like so this
this means this guy's probably
influential and he's influential enough
to the point where more people follow
him and he follows people but the
problem with only going on this is
there's a lot of people who will add
people and then just remove those people
like after they've added them back right
and so so that you know you've got
people to cheat the system by doing that
so the next thing you kind of want to do
is first of all you could analyze who
they're following and find out if the
people that they're following are
following them back and then also
probably in my opinion a better method
is to click on their followers and you
can see okay he's got all these
followers now it's a long process but
not really for a computer to go through
here so he's got you know 13 23
followers now what we want to do is
analyze who are his followers right
and are these like legitimate followers
that are truly may be interesting and
what interested in what this guy is
talking about and then also like are the
followers themselves influential people
so the next thing we want to do is like
tea path to class okay let's check out
this guy's probably brand-new he's got a
little egg but as you can see he has
zero tweets he's following 21 people and
has 0 followers in my book this guy is
worthless so you would take this guy
right out right at least this guy has no
um even though he's one of these guys
you know 1300 followers this guy's is
completely worthless so minus one right
then we want to check out this next guy
so let's see who he is he's got he's
following almost 2,000 people and has
about 609 followers so this guy is
pretty imbalanced the next thing we'd
want to do is kind of analyze this guy's
tweets well see like this guy right here
he's an investor right equities options
economics he's on into that kind of
stuff this guy well I'm everyone out of
time telling you what this guy's into
because I'm pretty sure he's talking
French here and I don't know French so
but I'm gonna go ahead and guess he
likes basketball it's so or she Syrian I
don't understand ring I don't even know
anyway this person is a fan of
basketball her name is basket basket
anyways so you would have to analyze
that I can't really analyze that one
let's check out trader value it looks
like the stock to its logo interesting
it's like almost identical of this stock
to its logo anyway this guy again we can
see the he's following he's almost got
like a two to one following the
followers ratio so again this guy's not
the most influential but he does still
have you know a lot of followers so
anyway you can go down the list and keep
doing this to these people but the next
thing you really would want to do is
starting with blue let's say well we'll
analyze this trader value guy so how so
we want to know how we want to know how
valuable blue is but the way that we r
value
blue is based on blues followers so
really you have to value evaluate blues
followers and we already said that the
following the followers ratio is not the
sole factor in fact I would say that's
probably like the last piece that you
should look at you care way more about
who is following them so again we look
at this guy and he's got the bonus of
having more followers than he's
following and then we look at okay
here's one of his followers so now what
we want to do is take it a step further
because again following the followers
ratio isn't that important really I
would say the first important factor is
how many people are following that
person and then how important are those
followers that's what I would say or how
influential are those followers but
anyway so now let's check out this guy's
followers right so we go over here and
we got you know all his followers and so
now we want to evaluate these followers
so then we've got this guy who
apparently is really valuable he's got
23 thousand followers and he's only
following 15,000 and then we couldn't
you know we you could keep going down
the line so you can do like five layers
or something like that and so you can do
that and then the next what you would
have to finally arrive to its first you
want to pull all this data then you'd
want to start evaluating the data and
deciding how much you want a value the
following two followers ratio and then
also the power of those who are
following this person how much you want
to evaluate that or value that times the
amount of followers they have and then
that's how important you know that you
give them a an impact rating or whatever
you wanted to call it and so on say
that's just kind of like a starting idea
to how you can start to evaluate
someone's importance or impact on
Twitter and you're still gonna have to
get to the numbers yourself and you
probably are going to want to use this
machine learning for that figure out
which one is the best buy what I would
suggest is handpick a few guys that you
would consider her girls they reconsider
highly influential people and then go
through their followers and just see
like okay how powerful of a following do
they have and um and then run that
through like your machine learning as
kind of like the the bottom line or
early I think of what i'm trying to say
here the baseline basically of what
you're looking for and then you can
start finding you know what makes what
what numbers generate what you're
looking for so anyway that's include
this tutorial hopefully you guys enjoyed
hopefully spurred some ideas for you
guys that want to do Twitter analysis
but aren't sure how to value someone's
account as always thank you for watching
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time